so what's the point for you where you're
just like all right it's gonna go
um I guess if it ever gets to the point
where it just from no matter what kind
of like because right now it only looks
really bad if
like Studio lighting has shined on my
[__] head and yeah very much see a
angle of my head right it's like all
right well that just looks like [__]
yeah but you know in a normal day it
doesn't look that bad and you can't tell
unless I'm like [__] showing you my
goddamn Scout and it's like all right
well I may as well just enjoy having
hair for a little while and then it gets
to the point where if it always just
looks bad or it always looks like a thin
down I'm like well I'll just get rid of
it yeah I'm not too worried about it I'm
pretty am I touching it now
I'm like you know if it ever looks like
[__] I'll just shave it all off I'm not
too bothered about going bold I I'm kind
of like no whatever but if I can enjoy
it but there's that weird stigma Riot of
people being like Oh I don't want to
like lose it all so they just like try
and [__] hold on to it because oh
yeah going bold and I'm like there's
nothing wrong with being bald yeah I'm
I'm kind of you know that'll be a the
next Arc in my life there's a lot of
dudes who look [__] great yeah yeah
I'm just I'm just enjoying it now I
think it's the choice thing because I
yeah I want a choice yeah yeah it's it's
not about not being able to rock a bold
look because so many guys lies con it's
about having the choice of having like
because it kind of just feels like an
identity right because once you once she
like commit to being bold it's kind of
it's kind of like a big identity shift
yeah right and it's like yeah you know P
A lot of people rock it and like [__]
good on you guys you know but I feel
like a lot of guys are just like I could
Rock The Bold look but I I like having
the choice of whether I can like style
my hair or not or just being stuck with
this stuck with this one look for my
entire life it would be pretty [__]
hilarious if trash taste goes on for a
lot longer and it just ends up being
three bold
yeah but like any advice like any guys
who are worried about this oh like just
just honestly keep track of it because
yeah you you're like your memory sucks
your memory [__] sucks if you think
if you think that you're balding you
probably are boating you know because
like you you'll be like oh I don't know
did I look any different one year ago
let's be honest you don't remember what
you look like one year ago you don't
remember if it's receded like one
millimeter or whatever but if you
actually genuinely take pictures that is
like concrete evidence of okay this
there I am I'm actually progressing uh
my hairline is actually progressing and
I can like visually see it versus just
you asking a mate being like do I look
like I'm balding because they're gonna
say no yeah because uh if if we see them
unless it's like super significant yeah
unless it's super significant but at the
end like if you see someone every day
you don't like normally see like a clear
change like I remember I still always
remember this where Conor talked about
like being a bit overweight before like
trash days and [__] like that and in my
mind I was like kind of stalking [__]
someone is actually talking [__] but
I've seen Connor so many times that like
his weight change before like he moved
to Japan and before like he started
taking YouTube more seriously like his
weight change was so gradual to me that
yeah
I didn't register it at all because now
when I look back and look like old
photos of when you guys were like first
visiting Japan yeah yeah I'm just like
oh yeah yeah wow okay yeah yeah it
definitely was bigger yeah yeah like I
you know I was losing him pretty
healthily like the way I was losing it
yeah yeah I wasn't doing it like rapidly
I wasn't like overnight yeah you know I
was I was stuck to eating the chicken
and broccoli for like four or five
months and worked out a lot yeah you
know I'm sure sure [__] I lost weight
exactly [__] sucked but it was way
easier as well because I I didn't have
as much of a social life like I found
now that having a social life and going
out and and talking to people and having
dinners people is so much harder to
actually like keep like on uh like an
actual diet for me yeah but it you know
and it requires a lot more self-control
and back then it was a lot easier for me
because I had the opposite problem where
like I used to be yeah I mean you look
at like the first episode of trash taste
it was like crazy oh yeah I remember
that I look like a different person
yeah you know how how even just a few
like a not even a not even going from
like uh like it's not like you ever got
like overweight or underweight but like
just how changing your weight in any
capacity yeah yeah really makes you look
different but you don't notice it in the
moment no yeah not at all I've been uh
considering so Sydney recently has
gotten uh like ICL it's kind of like eye
surgery yeah uh and I think I think my
stigmatism's gotten worse again I don't
know some there's Sometimes some I I saw
this uh really interesting it's it's
I've you know I find information in the
weirdest way sometimes and there was
just this random Twitter thread just
detailing the detailing the uh like what
people with astigmatism see and I've
never just had a moment where just this
holy [__] moment that just like me for
real because I just thought there's so
many things that I just thought were
just everyone saw and then I saw this
thread detailing this is what you have
uh this is what things will look like if
you have astigmatism and uh this is
going to sound like the biggest [__]
excuse of all time but you know there is
a reason why I find light mode easier to
read and follow and like this thread
details yeah you actually like the way
that the lighting works and the ways
that you see like perceived letters and
thin uh thin details things are clearer
if it's uh light mode is probably the
thing that's giving you a signatures
this is like a never-ending Loop of like
oh my eyesight [__] use light mode use
light mode my eyesight gets worse yeah
but uh Sydney got these uh synagogue ICL
surgery recently and I've never been
more jealous of someone in my life just
she like she just wakes up every day and
she's like my God I have perfect
eyesight it's even better than wear
contacts I know right [__] [__]
what does it feel like guys what does it
feel like tell me tell me yeah because I
remember I saw I think it was a Twitter
thread or a Reddit thread or something
like years ago
um of like this guy who used to do like
watercolor paintings of like Landscapes
and he would like paint the same like
picture differently depending on what
your eyesight level was so like the
worst eyesight you had the more like
faded out the same picture looked oh
yeah and I remember I saw that back in
like you know the beginning of doing
YouTube and stuff like that and I'm just
like oh that looks like it [__] sucks
yeah and so I started wearing the blue
light glasses because I was just like
well I don't want my I don't want to
find I can wake up looking at that yeah
I'll try and prolong it as much as
possible obviously my eyesight is going
to get worse the older I get that's just
like natural deterioration but like I
don't want it to like increase
considering I'm staring at a [__]
screen all day for my job right yeah
but uh yeah I really I really want to
get it but I'm I don't know I I have
this issue called just being chronically
lazy
I remember seeing this YouTube video
right that's uh that details like girls
what do you not understand about guys
right and uh one of the uh replies in
this uh Reddit thread was I don't
understand why guys would just refuse to
go to an appointment unless you
specifically book it for them and force
them to go and I'm like [__] I've not
I've never been called out so more like
so accurately in my life yeah because
like I've I've realized that I will
never like I could have like an issue
that's been bothering me for like months
and months and it's all sorted by just
going to like just sorting out like a
simple appointment but I I will never do
it myself unless like my unless [__]
Sydney does it for me I I have that
exact same problem with like not even
like appointments just like places I
want to go yeah you know I mean like I
can I could walk past the place and be
like oh that looks pretty sick and then
I'll talk about it days later and Aki's
just waiting being like so we're gonna
go or what and the only reason I go is
because she books it for you yeah yeah
I've always wanted to go and I'm like
why did I never just do this myself
oh my God why is that a thing and yeah
another comment was another comment
which was just like uh this this one
Sydney asked me this all the time right
where uh like a girl like walks past
each other in the street they have like
a five second conversation and they
could tell like what their best friend
has been doing for the entire past two
weeks guy goes on a [__] uh guys go on
a camping trip together spends like
three days together you go back home and
she asks what do you guys talk about and
you just go
yeah every time I go I drink it with the
boys yeah right right every time I'm
just like we even have it with trash
days as well I mean like I come home
from a trash taste recording he's like
oh what did you guys talk about in this
episode I'm like nothing much [__] what
did we talk about
nothing important
Cindy's like I cannot understand how you
could spend the entire weekend with all
of these guys and not know what you guys
talked about like how does that work
what's that Meme of like the girlfriend
like lying in the bed being like they're
probably talking [__] about the other
girls and then the guys are just like I
don't [__] remember
most conversations feel so
inconsequential like they're just kind
of like normal conversations where like
I don't even remember like conversation
I'm like that was weird yeah right yeah
that's unusual I know I I just know
sometimes like even I can have like you
know sometimes I do have like deep
conversations with my fellow Bros but
put in the moment of just like what did
you guys talk about my ability to like
to like get that memory back is just
like impossible unless there's something
that reminds me oh yeah I had this
conversation and we talked about this I
remember all the details of this super
deep conversation that we had but if you
ask me oh what'd you guys talk about I'd
be like oh [__] meanwhile girls have
this like [__] perfect photographic
memory of every little thing they talked
about so much so to the point where they
start like dissecting it with you and
it's just like all right all I asked was
what did you talk about yeah I wasn't
waiting for an analysis yeah if if
there's one thing that I've noticed as
okay as a guy something I will never
understand about girls right
um is sometimes you you are talk uh you
know you meet uh you meet girls there
who are like really good friends and
it's just like the moment I know that
there are girls who are like super super
good friends is for some reason like
they can tell when each other's periods
are coming and I'm like I'm just like
that that is that is something that is
beyond my level of understanding and I
thought it was just like a one-person
thing but the more girls I talk to the
more I'm like oh no yeah I I know when
all my mates everyone just have like
Tundra levels
I smell one percent more iron in the
years
yeah it's like girls I know what
everyone's menstrual cycle is actually
like I'm just like this this is not a
chart right yeah this this is something
that is beyond my level of understanding
as a guy you know I don't I don't know
how accurate it is for girls but I see
it I hear it about it every so often
like in conversation uh when I talk when
I talk to me while guys don't even
realize if another borrowers had a
haircut
it's like it could be the most obvious
[__] and you'd be like two hours into a
conversation with your friend and being
like oh did you get a haircut by the way
why are we so dumb
you just don't pay attention to
something like that yeah clearly not
yeah because when it changes too much
like like uh like our producer uh who
who had dyed his hair uh one day yeah
completely blonde and I remember them
it's in my first reaction when walking
into the office uh because the hair
color was different was I don't
recognize this person
that's me that's me with anime
characters yeah yeah I'm talking about
these characters that's why they never
choose their hair what color is their
hair okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
God why are we like this the absolute
state of men man